[Music]
we're going to talk about the Miss
America swimsuit competition we're going
to talk about Captain Marvel but first
here's a video of a fat dog this is from
an elementary school in Taiwan where
they adopted this sweet little dog eight
years ago to be their guard dog they
started feeding them snacks and now the
students have been forbidden from
feeding them anymore because he got too
fat his name is little white socks and
he's 110 pounds but it's really cute
it's well-intentioned they were all like
clearly in love with this dog fire that
dog I think you should just grow his
hair out and dye it blond because that's
what I did like most American security
guards to be honest this is probably too
sad to share but I was briefly a
middle-school teacher in New York City
when I first lived here and I was on the
fourth floor of a walk-up and there was
one security guard who was overweight
and the kids would get in fights on the
top floor and it was just literally like
I can't I have a security guy at my old
building and he died of old age oh very
so this is a suicide I just I was just
like well no one asked how he died
everyone was like yeah we know
[Laughter]
so I have two dogs but I for a while
just had one dog and I had a friend you
know him
Ryan dogs sit for me and then when I
came home he had fed not this Ryan
he had fed the dog so much that I
thought he had lost my dog and it was a
weekend serious it sounds like that your
little pup lost his swimsuit body I want
to talk about throw up that headline so
this past summer Miss America announced
that in the 2019 competition no more
swimsuit portion and Miss New Jersey
whose name is Jamie geo Loretto is upset
here's a photo of her she said quote I
worked all year for this body I went to
the gym everyday now for what so she
says that the swimsuit portion and
powers they took it away because they
said it sexualizes what do you guys
think does the swimsuit portion empower
sexualize what I mean how am I supposed
to know if these 19 year olds are hot if
I can't see all of their body that's not
really good it's not a talent like how
many dudes want to look at you is not a
tablet okay first of all the whole
pageant is what they look like like yes
that is their bodies but no one answer
has answered a good question question
well and one like know what the winners
don't it's not the answer the questions
it yeah what's it was like least dumb
answering the question should this year
the only question they should ask is
like should we bring back the swimsuit
what's the male equivalent yeah miss
miss you know mr. president I think
president
it's all about who's got the most skin
that's why I got my shorts on today yeah
a lot of shorts today a lot of short I
win I win the city's very hot in the
city so we're all wearing shorts present
appropriately so I can see a lot of
Jordans thigh but you guys are wearing
long-sleeve shirts are the shortest yeah
I love that both of these are classified
as shorts they should be different your
your shorts are twice as long as his
show Chris you're ranked appraise okay
speaking of empowered women
Entertainment Weekly first look at
Captain Marvel brie Larson check her out
she looks great in her uniform she's
ready to fight some bad guys what do we
think are we excited for this what
powers of chef
she can fly she has super strength she
is a part Cree part human and so she's
got everything going on part Cree part
human
yeah she's makes what Apollo Creed cap
no got her powers she was formerly known
as Miss Marvel but then this guy Marvel
exploded he was Kree and then part of
his like being in essence and everything
went to her and then she became Captain
Marvel so she got more powers and now
she's like immune to toxins and other
sorts of things like that that's the
origin story here Jude Law probably
gonna explode in this movie pretty cool
so now she's Captain Marvel and she's
Carol Danvers is her character name and
it's gonna be freakin sweet hmm what yes
it looks it looks great it's just it's
weird that Marvel has a movie called
Captain Marvel that's like if Tommy
central had a show called Captain
Marvel's we go back to talking about
swimsuit
she looks great but she would look even
better uniform usually the women they
just give him like a piece of string and
as they go out there and fight crime
she's dressed accurately
I like seeing like this is like I would
be scared if she rolled up on me woman I
pledge it crime-fighting uniform the
desert climate she's in breathe so
you're saying you can take her seriously
in full pants while shorts feel silly
picturing the superhero in shorts is now
very funny so you know he was like I
don't think the powers that they have
shooting fire and it's like
regardless of what you're running you're
gonna die it's not gonna stop you from
like a thing you know like a fourth
thing I get it lights and stuff this
will be I'll predict it right now
without even saying it's gonna have red
lights coming out of something some
green smoke coming out of something it's
gonna be like a lot of like
one thing that you didn't predict is
that this is set in the 1990s so they've
actually had to make Sam Jackson for
example look younger than he really is
CGI
[Laughter]
[Applause]
man G Smith and I don't know if he knows
but yesterday we were all dipping
tenders in some Cola because the lady
did that US Open and basically made out
[Laughter]
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah Dickinson and this is
cheers to you where I'm kicking off my
first round of the weekend by taking
shots to all the stories and people that
encouraged me to drink cheers to you
Pete Davidson for realizing that
something will go wrong with you and
Ariana would have finally open up those
butthole eyes and cheers to you Ariana
for getting an apology at a bishop Ellis
after he touched you inappropriately and
Aretha Franklin's funeral but in his
defense you do have the body of a little
boy
cheers to you Colton Underwood Oh for
being the next Bachelor now you can cut
down woman one by one just like you were
cut from four NFL teams cheers to you
United States of America for hitting a
record high in STDs but are we surprised
we've been getting non-stop since
November 2016
what up Trump Oh cheers to you one out
of 50 airplane passengers who find love
on an airplane the statistic would be
higher if anyone would love me back whoo
well I'm hammered Cheers
I think it's weird that Marvel comic
called Captain Marvel what would that be
like that'd be like in Comedy Central
had a show called Captain Marvel are you
guys still excited about Marvel
superhero movies yes well that just
that's every movie now so you like
movies or not every movie that comes out
as a Marvel movie it's so weird that
Marvel has a movie called cuz that would
be like if Comedy Central had a show
called Captain Marvel ok thanks for
watching please like comment subscribe
let us know if you like turns Geoff
[Music]